inflation is at a 40-year high pretty
good shape huh no actually inflation is
like golf a high score is bad as a
result many Americans are struggling to
put food on the table for their families
they're scared inflation is at
8.3% well first of all let's put this in
perspective inflation rate month to
month was just just an inch inflation's
measured in percentage points not inches
inches are used more for measuring
distance do you think it's good news
that you're not even aware how inflation
is measured no I'm not saying it is good
news but it was 8.2 or 8.2 before those
are the same number we're in a position
where for the last several months it
hasn't spiked it has just barely it's
been basically even I like how now
you're using your hands to measure
inflation seems more exact and I think
it adds more credibility to your answer
it sums it up also inflation is measured
year-over-year is the other I'm sure he
he knows that but Joe Biden does not
know that and that's the problem